donc là on peut dire principalement que
ma tenue ma tenue est finie donc voilà
un petit outfit basique si on peut dire
ça comme ça bonjour bienvenue chez moi
je m'appelle Asbel j'ai 20 ans je suis
maquilleur et depuis donc quelques
années je porte un style alternatif
japonais qu'on appelle le décorak c'est
avant tout une superposition de
vêtements c'est plusieurs couches c'est
par exemple vous allez mettre une jupe
en dessous un collant des guettes des
chaussettes haute un t-shirt avec je
sais pas encore des guetttres ou des
moufles c'est vraiment la superposition
qui est importante dans décor en faire
l'histoire en globalité des styles des
styles Harajuku parce que c'est ils sont
tous liés donc Harajuku c'est un
quartier de Tokyo dans lequel dans les
années fin 80 90 on est plein de styles
alternatif de jeunes en fait qui étaient
un peu en rébellion contre la société
japonaise qui était très strict et
cetera et donc sont né là-bas plein de
styles comme le Lolita le décora le
visual cake qui sont tous des styles
très différents le regard des autres moi
je j'ai fini par m'en ficher un peu on a
qu'une seule vie elle est courte donc je
je la vis pour moi